i explained
that these passports according to the
agent in the booth and i don't think he
was lying to me maybe he was but i don't
think so
he said to me when i went to show him my
bar code
he said it's okay i don't need to see it
because you just pop up on the screen so
there's there's some sort of radius that
they detect all the phones
that have a coveted passport on it and
yesterday i came across the border as
well again i did a quick little run
yesterday same thing didn't you i didn't
this time i didn't even volunteer the
passport didn't even ask me because that
apparently links to their system and all
my information pops up on their screen
and that's what you guys are gonna get
as well
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the spokesman for the canadian trucker's
freedom convoy a busy man bj dictor
welcome to the reuben report
you have no idea how busy and i started
my day with a car accident so you know
there you go oh geez are you all right
was this does it have anything to do
with the convoy
uh i'm great uh i'm gonna need a new car
unfortunately uh it's uh but what are
you gonna do such as life
such is life okay well we'll we'll put
that aside for a moment first off uh
where are you right now
and how did you become the spokesman for
this freedom caravan or as your prime
minister justin trudeau calls it this
group of islamophobic transphobic
anti-semitic crazy people
yes um
the i have a good friend from alberta
she is uh a metis
uh very influential uh metis native in
uh alberta she's from medicine hat
and her and some friends came up with
this idea that you know we're fed up our
economy is crushed we have no lives uh
one of them bridgette was just about to
lose her job
and uh they just decided we got to do
something let's let's do a convoy they
did one a couple years ago
and you know it was small and
unfortunately it didn't uh do some
internal wrangling
it didn't achieve what it wanted to do
so they decided this is going to be the
convoy of on all convoys so they put the
gofundme up and they figured well let's
get you know maybe we'll get a hundred
trucks we'll get like
i don't know twenty thousand dollars we
get a little bit of money
and we'll go and have our voices heard
and tamara called me i think the day
after they started the gofundme
maybe more or less day off maybe two
days but i think it was the day after
and she said oh my god i i need help i
need help with this i'm like what's
going on she said we started this thing
and it's everywhere it's exploding we're
already at like i don't know what it was
a hundred two hundred thousand dollars
whatever
and she said can you come on board help
me because you know she knows i produce
podcasts i do messaging and all that
sort of stuff
and i said yeah sure be my pleasure and
i also happen to have a truck as well um
so it was a perfect fit and there we are
changing the world so you guys put the
gofundme up and now as we speak is the
go gofundme still up i thought i had
heard something just in the last hour or
so that maybe it had been taken down
because of a violation of the terms of
service or something
oh that's the usual every three minutes
we get a thousand two thousand messages
telling us it's up it's down it's up
again it's down again everybody is
there's people are unfortunately a
little enthusiastic and they come with
some ideas of what's going on but right
now
as far as i know the last i spoke to
them
the funds now are held for review again
and i'll explain what happened the first
time
uh the mainstream sorry the fake news
media it's not mainstream
started
producing all these stories toronto
stars cbc yahoo news
that our funds were frozen because of
you know extremists and right wingers
and all that sort of stuff
and i said to the team don't respond
i've used gofundme i know they're uh
their protocols these are banking
regulations it always takes seven to ten
days for a new account
it won't be blocked trust me
and so they're going around building
this narrative oh they're there it's all
this speculation of why it's blocked and
it wasn't blocked and then we issued a
press release or once gofundme said yeah
you're good to go you meet all the
criteria we said a press release say to
all the fake news media we apologize we
don't know why
you would release such a story it was
never frozen for those reasons it's just
a regular protocol
and gofundme has been great to work with
and that was all right well i'll i'm
glad to hear that for the record what is
the gofundme let's actually say it here
so that people can donate i know a lot
of our audience has been donating
already
uh it's freedom convoy 2022. so if you
go there you type that or frito convoy
canada you'll find that um
but what has happened now
is now it has been frozen again once we
hit this once we came to positive a
story it was great it was great
everything was going along they're just
starting to do the first e-transfers and
we did get some money transfer or
whatever and then yesterday last night
boom
message on the screen ten point
one million dollars whatever
now it's being held for review
we think what happened and this tends to
happen a lot for people who use gofundme
it tends to happen a lot from the uh the
fake news media
what they'll do is again or the the
leftist politicians they'll get an army
of people brigading
your account and just you know overload
the system and then the algorithm
triggers
and then boom it's being sent for review
luckily now because there's been so much
international attention
we have a team of lawyers and a couple
of accountants that have flown in
they're on site now in ottawa they came
yesterday
and they're now starting the dialogue
working with gofundme all that sort of
stuff so i imagine a gofundme wants to
avoid the pr disaster of all pr
disasters and we'll be good to go that's
what i think right all right so let's
cross our fingers on that so in the
simplest in the simplest terms now that
we've all seen the videos i'm covering
it every day it's starting even to
bubble up a little bit in mainstream
media although as you say fake news
media it's tough to get these guys to to
pay attention to the right things
what is it that you guys want what is
the end game for the truckers and their
supporters
simple
and the mandates
and the passports
now the reason there's those two things
the mandates obviously that's the
vaccine mandates there's certain people
who want it don't want it freedom of
choice
i'm vaccinated some of you some our
people are some of them aren't
uh but it's their choice it's not the
government's uh choice you know it's
your body our choice no that's that's
not how it works here right apparently
the other thing is the uh the passports
as i think you saw uh when i was on
tucker i explained
that these passports according to the
agent in the booth and i don't think he
was lying to me maybe he was but i don't
think so
he said to me when i went to show him my
bar code he said it's okay i don't need
to see it because you just pop up on the
screen so there's there's some sort of
radius that they detect all the phones
that have a coveted passport on it and
yesterday i came across the border as
well again i did a quick little run
yesterday same thing didn't you i didn't
this time i didn't even volunteer the
passport didn't even ask me because that
apparently links to their system and all
my information pops up on their screen
and that's what you guys are going to
get as well
i mean it's truly it's an episode of
black mirror with a little bit of
minority report some total recall a
little bit of the matrix it's all it's
all happening right now okay so
the reaction to you guys
from
say the people that watch this show has
been pretty positive the reaction from
tucker's audience has been pretty
positive worldwide pretty positive so i
guess i got two on that which is number
one how does it feel to be in the
thickest sign i mean canadians are not
used to being in the thick of like a
true cultural
political moment i mean
that's number one and then number two
um
do you think that there's going to be
real change because of this i mean it
seems in the last day even though
trudeau's hiding you know the premiere
of alberta kind of was like oh maybe we
should give in to some of these demands
he was sort of like oh i kind of wanted
to do it but now maybe they'll actually
do it
uh how does it feel it's quite amazing
i've told this story a couple of times
to people that i went behind the
parliament buildings when i first
arrived here there's a park behind the
parliament buildings and there's a
bridge that crosses over to quebec and
i'm sure viva fry can expand on this
there were
there was an army i don't want to use
that word that that means we're violent
there was uh
there was
thousands thousands of people
crossing the bridge into ontario
with their quebec flags
and their canadian flags remember
separatism has always been a problem in
canada together and going to meet their
albertan and prairie truck drivers
and hanging out together giving each
other hugs and you know some guys didn't
speak english some guys didn't speak
french but they're fit they're trying to
you know figure out how to talk to each
other showing each other you know look
this is truck this is horn beep beep and
you know like uh it was it was wonderful
for the first time in this country's
history
you got this sense of unity
and one you know canadians not going to
like me saying this but one inferiority
complex that we tend to have in canada
is you do have
that that that unity of what it is to be
an american right
and for the first time i'm seeing that
in canada it's absolutely amazing so to
be in the middle of that it's
awe-inspiring are you shocked how
ridiculous the over-the-top over-the-top
attacks have been i mean that tweet by
trudeau it's like
it's like he's got nothing left nothing
left and
there was the other tweet from him you
know a year ago truckers are all heroes
and now truckers are all the bad guys
i'm not surprised in the least i
actually before he did that press
conference
i put on my twitter prediction
prime minister prime minister diversity
blackface is going to come out and call
us all racist and bigots and whatever
phobes and he's going to publicly shame
us why because extremists always double
down they only have one strategy and
that's it
where do you see this going over the
next couple days i mean
do you think that these gonna that
they're gonna really turn around some of
this stuff do you think think that this
gets protracted are you afraid that
maybe they give you an inch i mean this
has been the the thing that i've seen in
the last couple days where it's like all
right the premiere of alberta says okay
we'll move on some of this stuff and
then you guys dissipate you go back
throughout the country and then they
just ramp it up again a week later
knowing that you know you can do this
once but you probably can't do it at
this level twice
yeah that's what they tried with their
convoy a couple of years ago and they
were successful and basically divide and
conquer and the politicians got one
faction of their convoy fighting with
another faction and then it just fell
apart and a lot of people from out west
learn very learned that lesson that
we're not going to let this happen again
uh personally
i i honestly don't see this going on too
much longer that's just my i might be
wrong
uh the the morale on the ground is great
there's people dancing meeting people
falling in love like it's it's real it's
like a hippie part like we become the
hippies playing the videos man all the
music and they're cleaning up after
themselves and shoveling snow it's
awesome
and so
we've had some uh communications with
the police because we do have a
command center with ex-military and a
couple of ex-police officers there
ensuring that we have safety protocols
emergency vehicles have passed they can
go around things like it's really it was
really disorganized when we got here
because we were overwhelmed but what the
police have indicated to us
uh they were monitoring us for several
days
and they said all right you guys have
been peaceful you've been great we know
all that stuff in the media are complete
lies
keep it up uh we are we are not going to
act this is now
a political issue and the government
will deal with you
um the conservative leader was forced to
resign which i had told him a while ago
i'll get you and we did
uh he was chasing trudeau off a cliff
and well there you go so i don't see
this going on for two at some point
trudeau's got to realize all these
countries in europe
have uh abandoned the mandates it's the
easiest win in the world for him to say
you know what i the people i disagree
with them
but you know what the science has
changed we're going to follow the
european union and uh the uk and we're
going to uh we're going to remove all
the restrictions
will he i don't know right because it's
hard once you've called everybody a
bunch of racist bigot homophobes to be
like ah you know but they did have they
did have a good point uh you mentioned
that the conservative leader just got
voted out so i obviously i'm not an
expert in canadian politics but i think
i think i have a decent handle and in
essence you guys sort of have
too liberal parties actually one of
them's just kind of called the
conservative party they're not very
conservative in any way but then you
have the people's party which maxine
bernier who i've had on who's been very
involved in all this is the more
libertarian party do you sense that they
could gain a lot out of this and the
conservative and liberal party are just
going to morph into one thing like do
you see a real reshaping of politics in
canada because it's like freedom or not
pick one
i wish that were the case but no and
i'll tell you why and i know max
personally i spoke at his first uh
conference
the conservative party
after stephen harper lost
decided and i met some of those people
and they were i was in some of those
meetings and they said well let's uh
we're going to go more center and i said
you want to go center that's okay like
on social issues like i'm very
libertarian socially
that's great that's a good idea don't
follow those guys off a cliff well they
did so now they have to rediscover their
roots and become actual conservatives
but there's 45
uh mps that voted to keep
aaron o'toole the bald version of justin
trudeau so that's going to be a problem
internally in the party
maxime
but the problem with the ppc is
there's no ground game
the last two elections i asked him and
i've asked his other candidates i said
what's your geo tv strategy your your
great your get out the vote and max
always said what we're going to do at
the conference we're going to do it here
and i ask their candidates they have no
idea
so if they're going to be serious about
it they they i think they got to dial
back the grandstanding a little bit and
actually do community engagement and
they do nothing i mean that's how
politics works right you got to get
riding by writing
and they're doing none of it so i don't
know i i think the strategy that they're
using right now is just going to lead to
back to the old
liberal versus conservative but the
question is will the conservative party
become you know more center-right will
they with candace at the helm
yes
but she's an interim leader and it's
frustrating this the reason i got away
from a lot of this stuff is because you
say to them okay well takers use her as
an internal leader go into an election
as soon as possible
and then if she doesn't uh if she wins
then keep her as leader
but everybody turns into a bureaucrat
well you know the rules and the policy
guide and she can't like screw the rules
amen use your head use your moral will
and moral skill
but they have that inability and that's
the biggest thing that destroys that
party in all the years that i've known
it to candice bergen's credit at least
she called him out on the blackface the
other day parliament so that was pretty
good all right here's the here's the
bumper clip we're gonna clip this thing
and put it up on social media if you had
a message right now
maybe to justin trudeau and to the world
it can be two messages it can be one
message give me something that everybody
can see and hear and truly understand
what you guys are all about
if you're anywhere near ottawa
come down to trudeau's truck stop
right in front of his office in this
parliament
it is all peace and love
we are gonna solve this together it's
all unity it's a great vibe
yes people are upset they want change
and change is on the horizon but we're
going to do that when we stick together
we be unified we don't take the bait
from the left leftist activists and
we've got all the time in the world
we're gonna do it and i think once we do
once we're successful with it you're
gonna see all the provinces uh follow
suit and that might i'm hoping will have
a ripple effect in the united states
given the amount of support we're
getting from our american brethren in
the trucking industry and there's a
whole convoy of american trucks at the
border um i think it's not montana it's
another border
american trucks draped in canadian flags
would you ever have dreamed of thinking
of that ever happening that's the type
of unity that is going to come out of
this and we're right on the crust of a
new golden age where we all start to
listen to each other
how about that for a positive story and
a grand narrative bj i wish you guys the
best of luck anything i can do for help
you know where to get me and now now get
out there and change the world man
thanks all right brother we'll talk to
you soon thanks again
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
international issues instead of non-stop
yelling check out our international
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell